وفي سياق التوتر الاسرائيلي مع ايران كان
رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي هرتز هاليفي
حذر من ضربه وشيكا لايران بسبب نشاطها
النووي وقال هاليفي ان ايران تقدمت في
ترسيب اليورانيوم على نحو غير مسبوق واضاف
في كلمه له امام مؤتمر هرتز للدراسه
السياسيه والاستراتيجيه ان اسرائيل لديها
القدره على ضرب ايران وما تحاول ان تبنيه
حولها
ايران بقرين لقد تقدمت ايران في تخصيب
اليورانيوم ضمن مشروعها النووي في السنوات
الاخيره على نحو غير مسبوق وبدون الدخول
في التفاصيل نرى وجود تطورات سلبيه في
الافق تقودنا الى التحرك لدينا قدرات
ولغيرنا قدرات وهذا امر مهم من منظور
اقليمي ايران متورطه في كل شيء حولنا وفي
كل شيء ضدنا من خلال التوجيه والمعرفه
والاموال ومع كل عدو نواجه نجد بصمات
ايران نحن قادرون على ضرب ايران ولسنا
ساذجين حيال ما تحاول ان تبنيه حولنا